first a Spanish colony then an American
one Puerto Rico a small islands in the
Caribbean defines itself as a free state
associated with the United States
it's an Associated state whose citizens
have American citizenship but unless
they move to another state cannot vote
in the presidential elections and even
though they have a representative in
Congress he also lacks a vote all their
major issues be they political economic
or military lie under the federal
jurisdiction of the United States lately
there's been a lot of talk about this
territory not only because in September
of 2017 they suffered the harsh impact
of Hurricane Maria but also because a
few months before in May of that same
year where Tirico declared itself
bankrupt after more than 10 years of
economic crisis Puerto Rico's Public
Accounts could no longer keep going this
is because the islands public debt
surpasses seventy billion dollars and
another fifty billion dollars in future
payment commitments such as pensions
divya we're talking about figures that
are huge for an island that barely has
more than three million inhabitants
because of this in recent years Puerto
Rico has become known sort of as the
Greece of the Caribbean the simple fact
of the matter is Divya Puerto Rico is
insolvent but how exactly did they get
to this point well listen up
[Applause]
[Music]
lately there is a lot of discussion
going on about how to solve were -
Rico's serious crisis and how to stop
the exodus that the island is suffering
which we saw in a previous video but
first of all to address this issue I
think we need to answer a question and
that's of course what on earth happens
here what caused Porto Rico to become
quite so insolvent what led to it
becoming such a broke island well of
course the great culprit here is the
Puerto Rican government itself the
government that has been spending
uncontrollably for decades and has many
suspicions of corruption and an absolute
disdain for production but going beyond
Puerto Rico's government Washington also
holds a large amount of responsibility
for this whole mess Washington's
responsibilities in fact so great that
it wouldn't be unreasonable to say that
the federal government has been the main
driver of Puerto Rico's bankruptcy yeah
you heard that right the United States
has bombarded Puerto Rico with five
policies whose results were absolutely
devastating five policies concerning
trade regulations salaries and welfare
and if you don't believe me yes well
keep on listening
tax free debt
with the supposed intention of aiding
the Puerto Rican economy and helping its
government access the capital markets at
the dawn of the Jones Schaffer facts
Washington created a triple municipal
state and federal exemption on Puerto
Rico's debts interests thus if any US
citizen purchased Puerto Rico's public
debt he or she was exempt from paying
taxes on the interest that was received
[Music]
in other words if an American bought a
dent from a company they had to pay
taxes on the returns that they obtained
but if he or she invested in the debt of
Puerto Rico's politicians he or she
didn't have to pay any tax at all so you
might imagine that with such attractive
conditions people would be queuing up to
lend money to the islands governments it
was easy money that local politicians
didn't take long to spend and it was
aimed at achieving a single objective
and that was winning or should I really
say buying votes I mean what better
scenario could we concoct for
irresponsible politicians
[Music]
tax engineering
against all logic while the federal
government encouraged the island to get
deeply indebted it also made things
harder for the private economy in 2006
Congress abolished the so-called section
936 of the tax code a section that
provided significant benefits for the
companies that invested in the islands
and let's not forget it the Puerto Rico
is the poorest territory in the United
States while the fact is that this
incentive model was very very successful
four years the top to Puerto Rico grow a
lot even leading to it becoming a
manufacturing and pharmaceutical
powerhouse
[Music]
however once the incentives were gone in
2006 two years before the great
international financial crisis sweatery
coke began to fall into the abyss
overnight the condition of the companies
that had been supporting Puerto Rico
changed drastically
forcing investments in the island to
sink legal security well it was a bit of
a joke but that's not even close to
being all here
[Music]
the merchant marine law
this may be the most controversial point
of all and at the same time it's the
most absurd law the Jones Act which
passed in 1920 and is still enforced
forbids foreign flagged vessels from
transporting goods between two United
States ports thus a ship loaded with
containers coming from China cannot stop
in Puerto Rico because it has to
continue on to the mainland there the
containers destined for Puerto Rico are
unloaded and then loaded onto another
ship this time with a US flag in croute
which is obviously really expensive so
what's the result of all of this
well Puerto Rico has the most expensive
shipping costs of all Caribbean
countries something that not only
hinders trade we'll also makes exports
more expensive and reduces every Puerto
Ricans purchasing power
in fact to get an idea of this laws
implications we should mention that even
though Puerto Rico has an average income
approximately half of that of
Mississippi and is poorer than any state
in the United States its cost of living
surpasses the average state all of this
leads to a really crazy situation
[Music]
minimum wage and Welfare policy as if
all of that wasn't enough believe me
there is more the average salary in
Puerto Rico is the same as the federal
minimum wage that is $7.25 per hour the
thing is that as we've seen both the
development level and the average income
in Puerto Rico are much lower than those
of the US states causing this policy's
distorting effect to be well pretty
enormous
[Music]
you see the federal minimum wage in New
York or Illinois may affect very few
people but in Puerto Rico it's really
different the federal minimum wage is
the equivalent of 77 percent of the
average salary in Puerto Rico that is
the average salary of every profession
and every job on the islands this has
led only one in three people of working
age to actually do so and if this number
wasn't already abnormally low over 1/4
of people with jobs while they work for
the government
this means that less than 25% of the
island's population works in the actual
productive economy on the other hand the
federal regulation also implies an
abnormally high level of social benefits
for Puerto Rico's parameters in fact
studies show that for many families it
is more convenient who received social
aid than to actually go to work because
the income they receive is substantially
higher
[Music]
while folks the results of these five
federal policies has led to a huge
crisis a crisis that has lasted more
than 10 years which has caused or has at
least fueled the islands bankruptcy and
has generated a gigantic exodus of
people who escaped to the continents
especially of course the youngest
as we saw here on visual politic in a
previous video only in the last 10 years
500,000 Puerto Ricans have packed their
bags and moved to the continent that's
one in every seven people there's a lot
of talk about how to solve the island's
problems but the question is is Puerto
Rico's current connection with the
United States compatible with any of
these solutions well leave your answer
to that in the comments below as well as
in this survey and I really hope you
enjoyed that video if you did please do
hit that like button and don't forget to
subscribe to our channel for brand new
videos also don't forget to check out
our friends at the reconsider Media
podcast they provided the vocals in this
episode that are not mine and as always
thank you for watching
[Applause]
[Music]